climate
change is the biggest risk to the world
but when you turn it around if you're
part of the solution it makes it the
biggest commercial opportunity
this week 2021 is the year that money
grows
on trees meet a new class of green
billionaire a look at the entrepreneurs
that made their fortunes on transition
and how investors can get in on the
action every major investment
we make must go through an esg screen
and specifically a climate change
screen as the investment community vows
to adopt esg
who screens what's green there's a
massive risk of green washing
and and so we think you know investors
will start will get wise so they still
start
asking more questions this year and what
12 000
chief executives need to do for
sustainable development
the head of the un global compact says
we need a post-pandemic
reset governments and policy makers must
look at shaping this area of economic
growth in a green fashion and i think
that's what's very important
from bloomberg european headquarters in
the city of london i'm anne-marie
hordern and this
is bloomberg green
going green isn't just good for the
planet it's good business
2020 showed us that investing in
climate-conscious companies means
massive returns and those seeing their
personal wealth grow the most
are the names behind businesses working
to reduce emissions
it's a fairly new class of mega wealth
here's a look at the green billionaires
as the planet's climate crisis
accelerates the fastest growing fortunes
in the world
are now green thanks to a new generation
of tycoons
amassing wealth in the clean energy boom
the 10 billionaires on bloomberg green's
new ranking
showcased the explosive growth of
electric vehicles
batteries and solar power although not
every dollar in these fortunes is
derived from climate-aligned businesses
whose core products reduce
greenhouse gas emissions there's no
dispute that the transformation heralded
by these billionaires is well underway
elon musk tesla's chief executive
officer
became the richest person on the planet
earlier this year
thanks to the company's surging stock
price its gigafactory one is the world's
highest volume battery plan catl
the world's biggest maker of ev
batteries supplies
car manufacturers including tesla toyota
bmw and volvo its lithium-ion phosphate
batteries were cheap enough to let tesla
trim the price of its model 3 by almost
10 percent
last year long tea is the world's
largest manufacturer of solar wafers
established in 2000 the company supplies
about a quarter of the world's solar
wafers and modules
wang chuan fu set up byd in 1995
and warren buffett's berkshire hathaway
has owned a stake in the carmaker since
2008.
the company is converting the city of
shenzhen's buses
taxis and trucks to plug-in vehicles eve
energy
is the fifth largest supplier to china's
ev sector
with five percent market share and
counts daimler bmw
and xiaopong among its customers it
recently produced
lithium-ion samples for an ev battery
that can be charged in just
five minutes founded by x executive
ha xiaopong in 2014 xiaopong makes an ev
sedan an suv
the automaker provides free charging
services at 670 stations
across 100 chinese cities pratt owns
georgia-based pratt industries
the world's largest privately held 100
recycled paper and packaging company the
company also runs clean energy plants
to help power its mills backed by
chinese tech giant
10 cent neo has surged eight fold in
value
since its initial public offering in
september 2018.
the ev maker plans to build a network of
500 power swap stations where people can
change their car's battery
rather than recharge it by the end of
2021.
wabin developed his first wind turbine
in the 1970s
and set up enercon in 1984. although one
of the world's largest companies in the
sector
it has faced challenges in its home
country where delayed approvals for new
wind farms
damped sales it appointed a new ceo in
november
to engineer a turnaround established in
2003
first applied material mainly produces
films for solar panels
it makes more than half the world's
ethylene vinyl acetate films
an essential component of solar panels
that helps protect them from harsh
weather
let's bring in our wealth reporter
tracking those green billions devin
pendleton
joining us now from new york devon great
to have you on the program let's start
with the number one name on the list
not just the wealthiest out of the green
billionaires but the wealthiest
individual in the world
period was the driver behind elon musk's
wealth
at the top of this list was just about
the ferocious gain we've seen in tesla
it is it is tesla had an absolutely
extraordinary 2020. it means
the stock price was up 743 percent
uh tesla elon musk is the biggest
shareholder so of course that sent his
own personal net worth
through the roof he gained more than 150
billion dollars last year
and last year he was ranked among our
richest green billionaires this year i
mean he blew everybody out of the water
right and now of course bitcoin and
tesla's success
is why we're seeing these gains in these
chinese billionaires isn't it
it is so much of it ties to tesla tesla
has done
so well the demand is just there demand
is growing they've been turning out more
and more cars
so they've set these really ambitious
goals for the cars they're going to
produce
for the profit they're going to turn and
they keep hitting them which is
something that not a lot of people think
thought that
they could do a couple years ago and so
the more cars that are on the road
of course there's more demand for
batteries for these lithium batteries
which power the electric vehicles
and a lot of those electric vehicles are
being made in china
you look at the billionaires but how do
regular investors also
make money and push position themselves
for green
so a lot of these green billionaires i
mean they have gained a lot of their
money just through their own companies
they founded
most of these companies on our list are
publicly traded so
an investor can buy shares in those
companies and yes they've had
extraordinarily extraordinary rallies in
recent times so you could say that
they're quite highly valued at this
moment but you think about the potential
for these green technologies you think
about the demand you think about the
needs you think about
the net zero goals that so many of the
world's biggest economies have set
i mean there's no cap wow sky's the
limit
thanks to our wealth reporter devin
pendleton for joining us
coming up why the green transition is
both the greatest risk
and the greatest opportunity for
business former bank of england governor
mark carney next
this is bloomberg green
[Music]
welcome back to bloomberg green i'm
amber hordern in london
let's get your green brief with jennifer
zavizadja
here's the climate news you need to know
this week
energy giant shell says its oil
production has peaked and will now fall
by one to two percent a year
it's laying out a plan to transition to
cleaner energy with new targets for
electric car charging
and carbon capture a deadly smog over
india won't lift
until march that's according to a
forecast by the copernicus climate
change service
the toxic dust cloud has engulfed large
swaths of the country since
october a new study by harvard
university shows some
two and a half million indians die every
year from air pollution
jaguar is ditching the combustion engine
the luxury car brand plans to electrify
its fleet
in just four years and its sister
off-road brand
land rover will follow suit with its
first fully electric model
in 2024. the carmaker ceo says it has
the technology and knows how to do it
and vegan with a sweet tooth you're in
luck
nestle is planning its first entirely
plant-based milk chocolate bar
the new kitkat v uses a rice formula as
a substitute and took about two years to
develop
the biggest challenge ensuring it blends
well to get that
creamy chocolate texture and that's your
green brief i'm jennifer zabasanja in
new york
anne-marie now after the conversation
about climate is all about
risk but there's another side to that
coin just as the green movement has made
billionaires of entrepreneurs and
companies set net zero targets
investors don't want to be left behind
so when it comes to capital allocation
shanali basic takes a look at why
2021 is set to be the year wall street
really puts the e
into esg environmental disasters are
sweeping the globe
[Music]
from wildfires ravaging places like
california
and australia to worse weather all
around us
an estimated 8 200 lives were lost
due to climate-related events in 2020
the year of storms fires and floods
collectively cost the world an
estimated 210 billion dollars in losses
the cost of climate change is rising
so when it comes to esg issues for
investors and governments around the
world
climate action has to be a key issue
this year
[Music]
i think climate change is one of the
biggest risks of
our generation and the next generation
it's a massive issue
for all of us especially for what we do
as long-term ambassadors
there's something more here than just a
seasonal drift in the climate
we really need to have an honest
discussion about a transition
into a new future the world is getting
hotter
2020 was the second warmest on record
as corporations and governments rushed
to limit warming
in the race to cut emissions to zero it
can't come
fast enough for investors pensions are
teaming up with each other
and with governments to force change
among companies
it's this coordinated approach that will
enable us to pick up this
pick up the pace because if we're
talking about net zero by 2050
we have got no time to hang about at all
this year the un climate conference cop
26
will be hosted in one of the greenest
cities in the world
aiming to force more world leaders to
commit to ambitious targets to reduce
emissions
the event which will be hosted in
glasgow scotland will also have a
significant focus
on how financial services firms are
contributing to the fight against global
warming
former bank of england governor mark
carney a leading figure
in pushing the finance sector to
consider the risks and opportunities
posed by a warming planet
is spearheading efforts to make the
conference a pivotal moment in the
reshaping of finance for a net zero
world
his goal is for climate risk to be put
at the heart of every financial decision
it helps that leaders across the uk the
eu
and the us have made it a key focus for
change
and china japan and south korea have
made net zero promises
there are many ways investors are
getting involved from a rising amount of
investment
and green bonds issued by companies
looking to transition to a more
sustainable future
to the billions that are being invested
in renewable energy
close to three trillion dollars in
investment has been made in the last
decade alone investors are putting
climate at the forefront of how they
allocate their money
and it's happening at a greater scale it
covers everything that we do
so it it's top down and it and it's
bottom up so every major investment
we make must go through an esg screen
and specifically a climate change
screen to understand what the risks are
and are we being paid for them
as you heard there one leading figure
urging the finance community to put
climate at the core of
every single investment is former bank
of england governor mark carney
he's also the head of esg investing at
brookfield asset management
now that he's in the private sector he's
looking to turning those climate risks
into opportunities climate change
is the biggest risk to the world
but when you turn it around if you're
part of the solution it makes it the
biggest commercial opportunity
uh in the world in effect we're going to
rewire so to speak
the entire global economy uh consistent
with net zero and i wanted to be at a
place
that could play a leading role in fact
in many respects a defining role
in that why did you take this on what
sort of
generated that enthusiasm for you yeah
after i got to the bank of england
uh i shifted from thinking that others
were going i always knew this was a
major issue but
you sort of think well that's an issue
for others others are going to take care
of it climate policy the responsibility
of governments or
uh innovators to come up with the
technologies uh
and then realizing that it just wasn't
moving fast enough
and looking forward as was my then
responsibility as as governor of the
bank of england looking forward to
saying wait a minute there's
massive financial risk on the horizon
and it's going to be end up being closer
than we think in terms of
not just the physical manifestations of
climate change which quite frankly were
easy to see
uh the bank of england uh as you know
and many but many don't uh
oversees the world's fourth largest
insurance industry so we had direct
sight on these physical risks
but really what we're seeing is the
prospect of
enormous stranded assets potentially if
we transition if we succeed success is
failure for some companies in this world
on
climate change enormous stranded assets
if we succeed
but wait a minute if we don't then the
world's heading to three or four degrees
um and the financial sector was just not
oriented
so that's really um was the
crystallization for me
as you look at what is in front of
policymakers at this point
what advice do you give them to get
well it's interesting you know i think
the um
i think my main value add at brookfield
is really
about this transition
and how it cascades from the financial
you know what
what role do we play as brookfield in
delivering this transition
and what are the expectations of
brookfield's
investors its partners such as those
major asset owners
principally those major assets what are
their expectations what do they need to
deliver what do their citizens
ultimately deliver
and how do we how do we get there um
using our expertise so it's actually
more
it's really that as opposed to looking
on the
on the policy side coming up 12 000
companies have signed up for the un's
sustainability goals
but how does the international community
hold them accountable
more next this is bloomberg green
[Music]
welcome back to bloomberg green i'm
american in the london
now businesses are rushing to set net
zero targets and figure out where in
their supply chains
they can cut emissions and find
sustainable but
lucrative solutions and more than 12 000
companies have signed up to the un
global compact's sustainable development
goals
or known as sdgs and they range from
climate action
and sustainable finance to supporting
human rights but the latest report from
the global compact says the world is not
on track to achieve their 2030 goals i
caught up with ceo sando ogiambo and
she says we need a full reset it's a
really important time i think to reflect
on how businesses
have responded through the pandemic for
us at the global compact has been very
interesting because we found that during
this period businesses are actually
seeking out
a lot more information about how to be
sustainable
how to build resilient businesses and
how to strengthen their supply chains
through the covered pandemic
so what we've done with our companies is
really look at how we can integrate what
we call our 10 principles
for responsible business into the way
that they do business and for us that
means looking at things such as human
rights
labor rights the environment and climate
change
and it's just good to see businesses
wanting to figure out how they can build
resiliency and sustainability
going forward of course this doesn't
take away from the fact that business
has been severely impacted by the
pandemic the goal is to reach these
targets of the sdgs by 2030
given the impact of the pandemic do you
think these businesses can actually
reach that target
i fully agree at this point in time the
covert pandemic has truly slowed down
progress
on the sdgs what we do really need to do
is have a full reset around what we call
the decade of action
which is a call by the un secretary
general to really build the momentum
around the delivery of the sdgs
we believe that our businesses can truly
shape work around a couple of key sdgs
such as the sdg on gender equality
the sdg on decent work and economic
growth certainly the sdg on climate
action where a lot of momentum has
already built
up there are still not basic energy
needs in some of the developing world
how do you walk that line between
wanting to bring clean energy to places
but also making sure that everyone has
access to energy period
it's a delicate balance but you see
organizations such as the global compact
must be able to look at both sides of
the coin the advantage that developing
economies have is that they can actually
set themselves onto the path of green
growth in a way that perhaps didn't
exist for economies that are further
ahead on this journey so look at things
such as building in renewables into the
way that you build your energy sources
looking more climate adaptation making
sure that you can look at biodiversity
issues as you plan
forward for your business they see it as
a big opportunity for growth and for
green growth governments and policy
makers must look at shaping this area of
economic growth in a green fashion and i
think that's what's very important
what's the biggest push executives who
have to personally endorse these sdgs
what's the biggest push they need to
make in 2021 for me it's first that
continued leadership
shift and momentum second then is
looking at what i think are some of the
fundamental crises that we have right
now
there's also the issue of inequality and
now increasingly there's an issue
looking at decent work economic growth
people who are out of the job market
i think ceos must train their eyes on
those three huge challenges that are
before us
governments can't do it alone what do
you see the split as between government
policy
and private corporations making changes
no one entity can do it alone government
can't do it alone business can't do it
alone the government needs to continue
to be able to set the enabling
environment
through which business can prosper and
deliver i think there's a lot
that needs to be done around financing
for sustainable development
begun around policies as we talked about
around energy around climate
i think we need a multi-stakeholder
approach we talked about looking at more
international corporations so that
really
some of these changes can happen at a
global scale as well
[Music]
2020 was a decisive year for corporate
sustainability
with more companies than ever making
climate neutrality pledges
now the push got even more attention as
a result of course of the coronavirus
pandemic
joining us now is jonas roos head of
sustainability research
at bloomberg nef to talk about what to
watch out for in 2021 when it comes to
sustainable finance
jonas now let's start with net zero
commitments it seemed almost
every day companies were all trying to
one-up each other with green pledges
who is next to make a pledge the
announcements are accelerating
thanks to the pandemic in fact not
despite of it and that's because
the pandemic has shown us how fragile
our systems are and
has really taught us the value of
resiliency and we all know
climate change is the next big shock big
tech came in
first and they still have some of the
most ambitious targets banking has gone
involved
setting net zero finance emissions goals
and then in 2020 the story really was
oil and gas companies
coming into this in a big way and the
level of ambition may vary a lot between
companies and between
sectors but what's clear is the pressure
is on from investors
and from consumers and net zero has
become this point of competition
just like product just like price and
that's raising the bar
very fast on climate ambition last
year's
gold standard is this year is kind of
okay in particular we think the mining
and metals industry will start to
really catch this bug in 2021.
so net zero's really becoming the norm
in terms of
corporations we've also seen jonas cover
governments companies other groups
raising a record 490
billion dollars last year selling green
social sustainability bonds
really an esg gold rush what are we
likely to see when it comes to
sustainable debt in 2021
yeah so sustainable debt has been this
rapidly growing opportunity
double-digit growth year on year and
it's a real sign that there is more
demand for sustainable investment
products than there is supply
and with that you know with that
happening with that backdrop despite the
tough market conditions of the pandemic
this market has grown to three quarters
of a trillion dollars
by 2020 30 growth in 2020
80 growth over the course of night 2019
and we don't think that this is going to
slow down
we think biden will cause increased u.s
involvement in the market
social bonds which erupted as a result
of the pandemic
new innovations will open up this market
to new types of issuers
so um sustainability linked bonds in
particular
are something to watch for 2021 and
finally every bank
that i'm talking to these days is
setting up a sustainable finance debt
capital markets team or they already
have one
and what about finance flows we've seen
a lot of interest surrounding esg etfs
but investors are now really starting to
question how much is this green washing
that may be when you pull back the label
what's next for that environment with
esg etfs
yeah again esgtfs are this visible sign
that there is so much demand
for um sustainable investment products
and inflows in esg etfs have seen 205
and you compound annual growth from 2018
and most of that growth has really come
in 2020 as there's been this flight
of money towards the issue towards more
resilient investment
and you know there's been a response to
that demand with
and our colleagues at bloomberg
intelligence counted 330 new esg
etfs launched in the first three
quarters of 2020 alone
but the problem is these funds don't
really have any proper regulation or
even voluntary standards for what
qualifies for that esg label so there's
a massive risk of greenwashing
they really need better accountability
formal accountability
formal reporting standards and that will
come
but the really important thing
specifically
relevant here is the eu's rules the
so-called taxonomy which clearly defines
what qualifies as green and which from
next year will require that funds
disclose
against this there's no hiding from that
and that will really help with this
green washing problem
that's it for this week's edition but
keep the conversation going
follow us all along at climate i'm emery
hordern
and this is bloomberg
you